ils sont rassemblés là où deux de leurs
membres sont en garde à vue la
libération des leurs c'est ce que
demande cette vingtaine de personnes de
la communauté tchétchène rasoul team
erguy s est venu en milieu d'après midi
son père a été interpellé tôt ce matin à
dole
on est très solidaire le juge a donc
c'est la famille quoi donc tout le monde
s'inquiète
pourquoi que simplement alors qu'ils
étaient là pour arranger les histoires
aucun débordement les forces de l'ordre
ne disperse pas le rassemblement
nous sommes venus pacifiquement
nous n'avons rien contre la police nous
sommes simplement venu pour dire libérez
les ils n'ont rien faire ces deux gardes
à vue font partie d'une vaste opération
menée tôt ce matin en bourgogne franche
comté et dans tout l'est de la france à
dijon et à dole tout comme à
saint-etienne 3 et saverne à strasbourg
selon une source proche de l'enquêté
un homme s'est rendu de lui-même à
saverne dans le bas-rhin
l'interpellation d'un homme ce matin a
laissé des traces dans ce quartier au
dos mais les six personnes en garde à
vue at elle participé aux vives tensions
de ces derniers jours avec plus d'une
centaine de tchétchènes certains armés
en plein centre-ville de dijon sont
elles à l'origine des affrontements avec
des jeunes du quartier des grésillés
l'anc est menée par le procureur de la
république de dijon devra répondre à ces
questions
le parquet de dijon a ouvert une enquête
de flagrance des chefs notamment de
tentative de meurtre en bande organisée
dégradation en réunion violences
aggravées association de malfaiteurs
participation 1 groupements armés
un point devrait être fait samedi par le
procureur il pourrait dévoiler les
avancées des investigations